oh here he is the one the only oh
brother what I know about him Oh that's
me
[Music]
[Applause]
well here I am again with $1,000 for one
of our couples and if any of them say
the secret word this duck we have up
yonder will fly down pay him $100 the
way tonight is war okay Doug har revoir
he's a French duck mr. Penniman begin
them
Groucho we have a cab driver for you
he's mr. Maurice Simon his partner is a
special guest one of the great track and
field coaches of all time mr. Dean
Cromwell so folks you come in plays and
meet groucho marx
welcome welcome to the DeSoto Plymouth
dealers say the Stig avoid and divide a
hundred dollars it's a common word
something you find around the house Dean
Cromwell a anybody who reads the sport
pages know who you are mr. Cromwell your
fine looking fella Dean how old you well
my friends have been telling me for the
past 20 years that I am 55 well you
don't look any older you have any rules
for keeping in such good condition yes
sir
Groucho do not have any minor vices
don't smoke nor drink nor use swear
words no profanity Groucho no profanity
those are admirable qualities Beeman I
don't use profanity either unless of
course I have to give up some okay
now let's say oh you again
I'm always timing marks Maury Simon
that's it
where are you from Mari I was born
behind a dairy that my dad on the
Cleveland Ohio are you a baseball fan
mine all right more than just a baseball
fan I used to work at the Cleveland
Indian ball pie these are salt peanuts
and popcorn and ice cream you would like
to hear how they used to have been it
well I'm not crazy about it but I mean
it difference an overwhelming desire you
have by Talos I hid away with you II
left my keys in every pack you know you
tells another one no one of the last I
was there
I don't want to have a you sell ice
cream do that I have to go
ice cream use P me all Steve ice cream
Victor telling honey-coated ice cream
here cooling any fencing enjoy the game
and ice cream was this was this written
by Robert Browning the people holla like
that around the way you would like Dean
no no they're very very quiet because my
sport is individual sport let's see well
let's get by even track coach at the USC
for 30 years and 40 years
Groucho well my watch is stopped by
[Music]
there's a track coach give the boys a
pep talk like they do in football in
order to steam them up to win
I always did Groucho yes I told each one
of those boys that he was a champion I
called him champ told him that he was
going to be better tomorrow than he is
today that next year he is going to be
better than this year continually keep
that word champion in front of you but
did you tell them this collectively
individually and in the meantime you
keep them relaxed well how do you do
that you oh you know as a baseball
batter there talk to them gently
oftentimes you can tell the Millers
short story funny story you know it
better be funny if you're going to keep
them relaxed could you tell us one of
these funny stories
oh the audience goes to sleep we let
marisol some more peanuts
[Music]
to old gentlemen and bars sitting at a
table in New York City one gentleman
says I am 85 years old and I've never
used glasses the other funds said why
and he says I drink my liquor from a
bottle
let's had to paint that thing once more
he not only sells him he steams on there
and the other old gentleman said I'm
sorry Dean I thought that was all I was
true oh this is the we're still going
with a second one oh the other one says
I'm 86 and I have you beaten
I am 86 years old and I've never done a
day's work in my life but they got even
with him he died shortly after they
cremated him put his ashes in an
hourglass and he's been working ever
since
oh this joke right before attract me
well that joke would make anyone run
fast
including a person who told it Dean who
are some of the famous I like that joke
does it grow truth it's not funny but
it's sincere Dean some of the famous
athletes you've helped to develop over
the years three of the greatest
sprinters the world has ever seen
Groucho Charles W paddock - the first of
the fastest humans and then Frank Wykoff
the next of the fastest humans that
defeated every sprinter in the world and
then lastly Melvin Patton who now holds
the world record in the 100 yards and
the 205 yards and then of course the
heavenly twins ro Meadows and Bill
ceptin that broke the world's record in
the pole vault on an afternoon about two
minutes apart well you've got quite a
record you were the coach of the United
States Olympic team weren't you if I was
in London 1948 an assistant coach in
Amsterdam in 28 Los Angeles 32 Berlin
and 36 that's quite a record
[Applause]
the time you sent the both of you to win
some money here I know that Dean is
interested in that how about you Mari
you like money
oh I love it I was going to start you
off with a hundred dollars you have to
try to add to that by answering for
questions if you miss a question you
lose half of your bankrolling
you ready Zoe you selected you select
the general information quiz and
remember the more the question to the
weight the harder it is now what do you
want to start with ten twenty fifty
eighteen hundred fifty dollars that's
fine okay $50 one answer between you
what famous American do you associate
with Poor Richard's Almanack yeah talk
it over cuz one thing
Benjamin Frank Oh Ben Franklin is right
now I have $150 okay now are you gonna
go for just a 360 okay 60 by what means
the transportation did the crew of the
kontiki arrive at their destination it
kind of that this is that George Raft is
right now have $210 yeah you're getting
a free ride here Dean
untie 70 or whatever you say whatever
you think nice okay 70 what instrument
is used to determine the altitude of an
airplane altimeter that's a closer and
I'll have $280 well your climbing is
your last chance to be the other couples
what are you gonna go so you make just
40 $40 how many fellas did old King Cole
have looking cool with mints on it there
you go with you three
well fit Lucy you are absolutely right
three Fiddler's right
[Music]
you wind up with $320 thanks and good
luck in the DeSoto Plymouth dealers
[Music]
let's take a break for a minute I want
to say that beautiful car again and you
know the car I mean I certainly do so
let's go out to the Chelsea proving
grounds and see the magnificent new 1955
DeSoto well here we are
and there's the car the key word this
year Groucho is style sleek taut modern
style this new DeSoto's mighty fast
looking eager and new and different
designers talk about its taut surging
feel and look of power to you and me it
just looks like it wants to get out and
travel this is the smartest DeSoto we
have ever built longer lower and
comfortably whiter added inches give the
car a long slim modern style that's new
and different on the American scene take
a look at the new smooth slope of the
low hood the big graceful new grille
headlights bumpers perfect examples of
modern smart style huge glass areas
front and rear of course this year again
DeSoto offers you your choice of all
full power assist features and hang on
this year for the first time
DeSoto offers you two great v8 models oh
mighty firedome v8 now raised to a full
185 horsepower and at a completely new
low price and the super powered fire
flight v8 200 horsepower worth of
flashing automobile fire dome or fire
flight DeSoto's really got it this year
see the 1955 DeSoto tomorrow at your
DeSoto Plymouth dealer mrs. Norma
Ireland and misters
mr. Thomas Craddock has some things to
discuss with you Groucho right now and
he'll er folks to come in please and
meet groucho marx welcome to you betcha
live say the secret word and divide a
hundred dollars it's a common way
something you see every day Norma I land
and Tom Craddick mrs. island where are
you from Rogers Ohio was what I thought
you'd be from Island
well could you give us some idea of your
age whoa party 40s that's a nice age
it's a nice age you're young enough to
have a future and old enough to have a
past
what don't know wife does your husband
do I assume you're married yes he is an
industrial engineer for California
Institute of Technology Jet Propulsion
Laboratory in Pasadena California yeah
that's a very imposing list of titles
and let's see now you're at Thomas
Cradock cuz that's you and how much
product where were you born
Tom mystic georgia mystic why do they
name it sounding sir sir mr. to me i
don't know
well where is mystic exactly oh it's
near Tifton now that play is that up
where is Tecton named mystic oh it's
about 30 miles from Valdosta are we
getting there anything yet about the
American miles from Jacksonville
Jacksonville oh now now you're talking
Jacksonville Florida yes
are you married huh yes sir you see a
mistake I'll most guys I you know no sir
she's a Tifton attempted Madison what
kind of wife have you been doing since
you left Mystic oh I've been farming a
little bit of everything and worked for
Fred last road service Oh must be
cleaning up man yes sir do you have any
other job besides the rugs
oh uh soldier own son which side you
sell it on well it's pretty blue outside
yes sir it's how is the jewelry business
well it's pretty bad right now why is
that it's close to Christmas they ought
to be a lot of it well I sold three
watches in one ring since since when oh
god it's been a while watch what this my
wife bought one of the watches your wife
bought the watch and I bought the ring
but that's
Tom I think if you work real hard inside
of six months you could build your
jewelry business into a shoestring now
mrs. island are you a housewife yes I am
do you do anything special for
relaxation any hobbies well I'm an
amateur contestant you mean you've been
on a lot of shows no not not shows I
enter other kinds of contests
well what kind puzzle contest limericks
and statements and jingles and have you
ever won any of these contests
well I won over 100 prizes I think that
which isn't a large number at all well
you must be pretty smart how much money
everyone Oh proximately between three
and four thousand what are some of the
prizes you've won you probably have 300
electric toasters at home no I'm not
that good oh you got 200 which would you
be interested in buying a watch here
from
well you're a nice young couple and I
wish both of you lots of luck Norma you
ought to be a whiz at the quiz he I'm a
little scared of you
oh no no don't don't give me such a
disadvantage I'm wrong
well remember we start you off with a
hundred dollars and if you miss a
question you lose half of your bankroll
no matter what it amounts to at the time
are you ready in the race for the
thousand dollars the first couple one
three hundred twenty dollars and the
secret word is wall okay here we go you
select a dictionary quiz
remember the more the question is why
the harder it is talk it open what do
you want to stop me you're stirring
$100 you're gonna start with a hundred
on this okay what is a leotard le ot ard
come on solo person or individual no
it's a it's a form-fitting garment worn
by ballet dancers but you lost half your
original hundred you now have $50 well I
don't get discouraged what are you gonna
go for now
none 90 okay what is a lexicon lax ICO
in dictionary dictionary dictionary is
right now have $140 now what
dee dee what do you call the blanket or
shawl worn over the shoulder by some of
the people of Mexico
time's up Wyndham Mandela Manta
no it's a serape we lost half a hundred
and forty you now have $70 all right is
your last chance to be the upper couples
what are you gonna go for seventy
seventy many universities have a
Campanella CA MP Ani le what is the
Campanella is it a tower clock town well
that's close enough it's a bell tower or
a steeple that we give you and you wind
up with 140 dollars
thanks and good luck minnesota plymouth
dealers you took a tough category
[Music]
freshly invited a married couple come to
our show tonight
I always married couple and if Reverend
and mrs. Karl das will come in I'm sure
you'll discover some pretty unusual
topics of conversation so folks de green
please and meet groucho marx welcome
welcome for the DeSoto Plymouth dealer
satyrs take it away
say the secret word and take home an
extra hundred dollars it's a common word
something you see around the house
Reverend and mrs. Carl Dorr say I don't
think we've ever had a minister on the
show before not really a coward but I
just may let you do all the talking
hidden why are you from Reverend is that
what I should call you Reverend call me
Carl calm as party one thing so just
leave there ever lost okay
I was born in Long Beach grew up in
Southern California and mrs. Dodd what
is your place name Helen Helen well
that's good where's your church your car
at the present time I'm not serving a
church I'm lecturing and preaching on
invitation in churches throughout
Southern California Oh sort of a guest
conductor yeah how long have you been
married Helen her 17 years you have any
children yes I do
boys are girls I've got some of both how
old how old are these children well um
Richard and Dorothy and Donald are 12
and Teddy and Laura and Susan and Elaine
are nine and when I am and greed are
eight you had triplets and then you had
quadruplets well stitch Reverend I admit
you got some pretty important contacts
but
it's pretty hard to believe is this true
Helen
it wasn't incredulous as it sounds
because well I like the triplets they
they weren't really exactly triplets
well then the same age but one boy is
the America well he looks like my
husband and another boy Indian when he
was born no and not a voice part Indian
and the other one of the other three is
the Brazilian and Portuguese and English
and our baby is only hundred percent
American he's Blackfoot Indian and then
some are Japanese well it's pretty clear
the whole thing listen before fifty
thousand pediatricians go out of their
minds you better explain this car
whatever it is very simple we adopt to
me all children you've adopted twelve
children they're all of different races
and nationalities
[Applause]
and they're all of different races and
nationalities uh I'm speechless with
admiration I think you should get the
handshake really you have to do taking
care of them in well do the racial
differences to present any problems
Helen well the children don't really
realize uh well they know it
theoretically they're different but does
make any difference for instance uh the
two oldest boys always play cowboy and
Indian but the the blonde blue-eyed boy
plays the Indian in the cut of the the
Indian ice please
cowboy when lemurs have fun chasing each
other that's wonderful
I'm sure there must be a story behind
these youngsters Karl could you tell us
how all this happened
when we were married we wanted a normal
family as and a couple does and when the
doctor told us we couldn't have children
of our own we thought naively Oh we'll
adopt them and then we discovered that
for every normal blue-eyed blond-haired
youngster there were a dozen or more
couples waiting for that child but that
the mixed-race children were classified
unadoptable because neither race wanted
them so we started taking mixed-race
children
Ellen I realized running your household
must be a full-time job but you ever get
a chance to relax if you have any
hobbies like gardening I do gardening uh
really my name hobby now outside of
taking care of children is our writing I
just finished writing a book about my
family's called a family nobody wanted
McCall had a small part of it in their
September and October issues and on his
book coming up its king I mean it come
as handsome come well this is on sale
now in the books but it's been on since
September 2013 well all you people could
do her a big favor by going out and buy
one this copy you make a little funny
how it makes a wonderful person present
and yeah fine plea for tolerance thank
you and thank you
gosh great polite around
Reverend does you have a wonderful time
I mean I want to ask you one question
with the experience you've had so far
would you do the same thing all over
again
the Sherwood Groucho it's been an
enriching experience for us we've
discovered for one thing that all races
are basically alike these differences
that we call racial differences that
divide men or cultural differences
there's something that's acquired after
birth it's true that all people are born
alive that's true all people are born
alike except Republicans and Democrats
as far apart as the two poles well I
think you've done something for your
country that Israeli equalled you've had
a small League of Nations all of your
own and it's too bad that more people
don't do this
you know we sent a care package away for
ten dollars or something
two career something we think we've done
a wonderful job someday in the far far
distant future Reverend and you too
Helen when you both face-to-face with
Saint Peter you can Satan you tell him
that Groucho sense
well it's time to with a lot of money
and I think everybody in our audience
all 50 million of them they're all
pulling for you and that probably even
includes the other contestants here
tonight all right this is a dictionary
quiz in the race for the thousand
dollars Dean Cromwell and his partner
are still leading with $320 all right
what do you want to start with $50 6810
Healy 1 William buck was dangerously all
right what do you call the front or face
of a building listen front elevation no
it's called a facade FAC ad
you lost after $100 you now have $50
come on Oh enough of this nonsense
what are you gonna go for now 90 what is
the word for a remedy given to
counteract the effects of a poison
antidote antidote is right soon I'll
have $140 all right now what are you
gonna go for Needy Haiti what do you
call the sheets in which the blade of a
dagger is enclosed scabbit is right
you'll all have $220 you've had 80 9100
now you gone for 70 what do you cook 70
what do you call the strips of wood that
make up the sides of a barrel
staves is right one document
$190 I'm a little crooked Anaya but I
couldn't help but thanks and good luck
you did pretty good
[Music]
that means with mr. Dean Cromwell and
mr. Simon with $320 in just one minute
get the chance of the DeSoto Plymouth
$1,000 question come inside the most
luxurious stylish interiors in an
automobile today inside the sparkling
new 1955 DeSoto
here's beauty and comfort at the height
of fashion
DeSoto this year makes use of glamorous
nylon glistening metallic thread fibers
the softest shoemaker's leathers weaves
and pattern that spell style and luxury
smooth gleaming chrome sets off the
interiors interiors incidentally
available in over two dozen color
combinations here's the ultra smart
double cockpit effect of the brand-new
DeSoto instrument panel in a class by
itself for beauty and set right on the
instrument panel the new flight control
lever yes inside or out the new 1955
DeSoto will catch your eye with it's up
to the second style and beauty see it at
your DeSoto Plymouth dealers now DeSoto
style for tomorrow and here's the
winning couple Dean Cromwell is fondly
George before you go ahead we have
something a little unusual here during
the commercial we've been having a
conference backstage about the quiz we
just finished we asked a question for
which the correct answer is facade FAC
ad e Oh mrs. Doris said front elevation
and some of us feel that might be
acceptable so we think the best thing to
do is to bring them back next week for a
chance at an extra thousand dollar
question
[Applause]
his partner are still high for the night
and still get a chance of the
thousand-dollar DeSoto Plymouth question
tonight right all right Ellen come on in
[Applause]
well Dean we're through with the
Sprint's now we're up to the mile run in
there it is
most of the major countries of the world
have well-known news services like The
Associated Press United Press and
international news in this country for
$1,000 what is the famous news agency of
England do what is the answer you two'll
decided upon Reuters writers is
absolutely right
[Music]
when the thousand dollars plus how much
in the quiz George $320 well thanks and
good luck from the DeSoto Plymouth
dealers
[Music]
now here he is the one the only I
thought he went out with the old year oh
that's me
[Music]
Here I am again with $1,000 for one of
our couples and have any of them say the
secret word the duck will fly down and
pay him $100 the way tonight is water
okay Donald scram go ahead with this
thing yeah George all right Roger we
have a young married couple for you
uh-huh well you mean for each other yes
the young married couple our sergeant
and mrs. Sylvester Nelson folks do come
in please and meet groucho marx welcome
for the DeSoto Plymouth dealer say the
secret word and you'll take home an
extra hundred dollars it's a common way
something you find around the house
sergeant Sylvester nose so you get
you're a marine judging by the uniform
is that right that's right - uh-huh
sorry you don't have to say so to me
just call me kind of let's all I had a
nutty anyhow your name like Sylvester
I'm sure you must be a fighting marina
oh I sure AM they call me ski though but
they do huh
what do you do from the greens playing
the band no I'm a staff sergeant
machine-to-machine gonna in that case
sir you can you can call me Groucho
[Music]
mrs. Nelson that's you what is your
first name my first name is Colette
Colette Oh French a Polly Buffon say
by the way excuse I've usually feel a
party when I was a - I can I'm going
fishing in the body where box and Fran
said you call home
Colette well I was born on Glenn my boy
Attenborough I'm where I'm Glenn
don't go lamb wee-wee no I mean just you
I don't know where he's born I'll ask
him later
Colette now that you're in America what
do you think of us in our ways did you
find us confusing when you first came
here
oh we sometimes but I think my work
experience was on a train ride from New
York to Wisconsin doing the Wisconsin uh
when I go to Green Bay
we already saying my supposed baby and I
was are telling me Sookie who's Fifi
nice inch bubble it wasn't Fifi
accompany you on the train Pluto saying
no she must cousin too
[Music]
well that shouldn't have upset you I I
once had a bike on a train myself
that's a pretty old joke collect what I
do don't you think it's funny I had a
bite on the train
which joke didn't you hear the joke I
said don't let it upset you I once had a
bite on a train I had operate well I
don't think I can explain it to you
Sylvester why don't you explain it to
her you know huh malas he's gonna have a
berth on the train yet a Bertie looking
asleep but you you're to give birth to a
baby I'm okay oh hey bro explain the
rest of it later son you know in 40
years in show business this is the
lowest I've ever stood when one
contestant has to explain my jobs to
another
well it's been a real education talking
to you too and I wish both of you
success children and happiness yeah and
if you ever see Fifi again get my left
hands up clicking well get the whole
later month now let's play you betcha
life we start you off with a hundred
dollars you try to increase that
bankroll by answering any four questions
in the category you pick yourselves if
you miss a question you lose half of
your bankroll is that clear Colette
oui oui you selected music and remember
the more the question is why the harder
it is now you can start with a ten or
twenty or fifty eighty all the way up to
hundred seventy dollars
alright in music what is the mechanical
device used to mark the exact temple
[Music]
what is it in French
[Music]
you can see me once again water sitting
Hungarian wow I'm sorry
it's a metronome no movie hola
you still have half your $100 dual alarm
French sorry
yeah alright now don't get discouraged
I've got a long ways to go you still
have $50 now what are you gonna try this
time alright the AC mob round and that a
I wrote a song back a 1911 that keeps
popping up regularly I'm sure you can
identify it now you listen okay jack
beautiful now oh you beautiful doll is
right that is right apps you know have
$130 no what do you want to try how many
pranks 90 according to the folk song who
wore sardine boxes - topsis in place of
shoes hardly according to the folk song
this is the this is an old American song
and this is one of the lines in it who
are sardine boxes - topsis in place of
shoes do you know George yes I think I
do palette oh uh Clementine My Darling
Clementine that's right you win $50 but
unfortunately you lost half your 130 you
now have $65 alright now here's your
last chance to be the other couples and
don't be discouraged hundred was alright
go the bigger the money the heart of the
question your woman I don't want to
alarm you hundred billion onerous what
was the place name of the great Austrian
composer Mozart what was his first name
[Music]
I'm stuck I'm stick well it's a
ridiculous name is Wolfgang
oh I've never guessed it no if you'd
have thought of Lea of Errol Flynn you
too guessed it now
[Music]
we wind up with $32.50 thanks and good
luck from the DeSoto Plymouth daily
diary Danville
the young lady with a very interesting
job Miss Maryland Pierce her partner is
a special guest one of the best-known
names in the world of goth mr. Jim
farrier folks do Quinn please and meet
groucho marx welcome to you betcha life
say the secret word and divide a hundred
dollars it's a common way something you
find around the house Jim Ferrier put it
there Jim I'm glad to meet you I'll get
around you in a minute Jim you practice
your backswing and
I'll practice my approach let's see
you're a Marilyn Pierre where's your
home originally Maryland Newport Rhode
Island
Newport oh that's a pretty swanky place
I was thrown out of a hotel there did
you have a job back in Newport no not
Newport I moved to Boston at an early
age Oh bond a virgin model here a model
mm-hmm are you still a model no not
anymore I found that it wasn't
intellectually stimulating Oh Oh some of
my best friends are models I
still be a model and have intellectual
satisfaction you could be a cover girl
for the National Geographic I don't look
at much of a challenge I thought of what
do you do now now I'm a dog trainer a
dog trainer yes and that gives you
intellectual satisfaction oh yes why is
that when a dog digs up a bone does he
tell you it comes from a dinosaur no but
breaking the language barrier between a
dog and human being is really an
accomplishment
this'll certainly is after all from
human doing it much simply they kick him
just a call like a dog so those the only
ones you concentrate on uh yeah what
about an old cocker spaniel new wouldn't
mean let's talk about your wife as a dog
trainer that sounds very interesting and
most unusual for a young attractive girl
where do you where do you train them
well I train dogs at their own home I go
to home and a trainee owner do you train
the owner yes what did he do get on his
hands and knees and run around the room
no not quite I I trained the dog and
show the owner how to manipulate the
leash and correct her commands to give
to the dog you've been standing here all
this time and I'm listening
isn't it funny I didn't even know you
were here never underestimate the power
the power of the Philadelphia bulletin
where are you from originally Jim I came
from Australia Oh down under Antipodes
and yes I've been here 15 years I came
from Sydney originally is that so why'd
the professional golf here 15 years what
are some of the important job
tournaments that you've won I know
you've won many on well I won the
National PGA Championship in 47 I won
the Canadian Open twice I've won five
Australian championships and quite a few
of the big money events around the
country
I now lakeside club here in Hollywood oh
I see and hope to have you ever one day
yeah well do you ever play at Hillcrest
oh yes man [ __ ] playing there next week
Oh tournament no no just a little
friendly game if you have a loose dollar
- I have a loose dollar but I haven't
got a lose moment I play golf - you know
what is your handicap there Jim well as
a pro I don't have a handicap well
congratulations
how was it a tall handsome man like he
was married oh I'm married I have one
you just said you didn't have a handicap
well I mean you got the same handicap
that fifty million other men had well I
don't consider my wife a handicap
now you had a bad lie Jim which you
recovered very nicely well I'd like to
go on talking to you too but it's time
to play you bet your life in the race
for the thousand dollars the first
couple won $32.50 and the secret word is
water now you select the general
information anyways and remember the
more the question is wait the harder it
is I think you better stand leave you
don't scream 80 well that's kind of a
yeah about 50/50 this is yeah mm-hmm
Tiffany but alright what type of much
and indicates his trade by suspending
three golden balls over his front door
upon broker and the hotshot that's right
now I have $150 what are you going to
try this time you have a hundred and
fifty 150 dollars
you want a Haiti a 90th for THD Oh 100
hundred huh you agree with that J on a
LAN Ludlow intellectual 8080 what is the
monetary unit of Italy yeah lira is
right now I have $230 what do you want
now little one or a big one big one
Tejada the little one Therese
you're the 69th the protecting are
really good 60 there is no separate the
norm all right as a 70 or 80 you can be
80 and family cooking what is the
complete membership of the United States
Senate and I want the precise number how
many members in the United States Senate
[Music]
96 I believe it is 96 96 is right are
you gonna go for 61 make me a 60 60
ma'am can you do I don't look at me with
those big black guys
I think 60 be safe
I'm Scott you know me well I am Cuban
living game all right sexy all right how
many justices are there on the Supreme
Court and I want the exact number 12 one
answer people say - well no I'm sorry
it's 9 Jim lost happy or $300 you wind
up with $150 well thanks and good luck
mrs. soto plymouth dealers buried in
windowless
macho we invited some schoolteachers to
the show tonight just before we went on
the air our studio audience selected
mrs. Evelyn sorrows her partner mr.
Floyd Humiston as an unusual occupation
so Fosdick win plays and meet groucho
marx welcome welcome to the DeSoto
Plymouth dealers they received word and
divide a hundred dollars it's a common
way something you find around the house
[Music]
in GQ Evelyn's sorrow them and Floyd a
human Evelyn I'll start with you because
you're a girl you're a teacher is that
right yes oh what a nice little teacher
why your front page
I can't you del Monte are you married
yes my husband goes to Caltech oh no I'm
sorry to hear that
[Music]
Floyd a human man yes'm hmm how old are
you were unemployed
I'm 24 how mr. Penniman says you have an
unusual profession what do you do Floyd
well I'm named like Floyd you missin I
should guess you're a flute player with
the Philharmonic what what do you do
well I uh train once crossing you
represent light ringing Lyons
you mean the van and storage company Oh
kind of these meet how long you been
doing this kind of work Floyd about half
an hour oh don't say anything to get on
this yogi
brains lines he probably sells pencil
sharpeners it used when my head has been
coming to a point later my father was a
lion trainer and he's and so I've been
on it since I've been about eight years
old what did you do you start training
my spice when you look here well no just
being around them you say your father
was a lion tamer what happened did he
collect a severance pay
no he's retired using the termite
business name
hey my team us he must cut quite a
picture crawling under a house with a
whip a chair and a loaded revolver
where did he find his time eyes on the
lion uh well I I don't actually I have
been worked winning a little bit but
what your mother in the animal training
business no she was a mirrorless with
the circus flying onions yeah mm-hmm and
that sounds like a typical American
family no he trains lines his father
chases time ice and his mother swings on
the air
Macauley ideal American home be very
restful around there on dinnertime
do you have any brothers and sisters or
the lines away with them your ever
half-sister drinking yeah
mean you keep the lion in the house
I use doing a half-assed s is better
than none I get which have you got do
you remember well uh fly why you chew on
a hunk of raw meat for a minute while I
engage this if you'll teacher here and
repartee how old are you 24 24 how long
you been teaching school I'm starting on
my second year really well aren't you
the children distracted when you walk in
a school room
no I teach girls oh why do you why do
you teach these girl
I teach homemaking Oh making what's that
carpentry and things like that
no among other things it's cooking and
sewing you mean you're the one who
teaches these modern girls how to cook a
you're a wise man and smog
let's get back to your lions do you all
not even selfie yes I do grass Ya'alon
moon through his Fagin sailors fighting
Oh No chris fehn where's peeler said
Fagin now oh well is is it to a home I
see is he pretty friendly around the
house
oh yes he's very friendly lives in the
house and used to sleep in bed with me
what happened no my wife didn't like
well I think there's some justification
for that they got her lying too now why
do you keep sailors to posnick now oh
well I i keeping my up in thousand oaks
and that's uh we have a lot of animals
compounds and one thing another up there
and keeping a tree you know in the house
you said in a thousand oaks oh well like
this this has powers no disposable nella
so you might have cut one down
at anything like 29 ponds oh no I'm just
about the spoon
how do your neighbors feel about this
don't they complain no they have
elephants
[Music]
Wow that I can understand having an
elephant the house is logical but having
a lion that's ridiculous
hmm hmm you must live a rather
interesting life Floyd with a lion on
the house what do people say when they
ring the doorbell and the lion answers
oh well not too long ago why we're the
Dutch doors in our house you know the
kind of open up one at a time and so
mean oh you know it's uh can you stand
on Barnes you know when they start them
in half you know the bottom part open
something in the top part open so this
is like your half-sister well anyway so
this Fuller Brush man all right here to
sell me some brushes and so I was
talking to him and so big'uns stuck his
head up over the door and the top of the
door and so I still I have the man's
brushes and
well you think this Brush salesman
thought the line was your wife leaving
your wife afraid of begging there
oh no she's not no she's not afraid of
the meter begging anybody else I guess
you have your wife pretty well trained
by this time oh well one of the hardest
things in the world a train they have
the training of a tiger and the
stupidity of a lion the
[Music]
let it go you're not going home tonight
anyway well I hate to break this
conversation of it's been very
educational and extremely interesting
however it is time to play you bet your
life in the race for the thousand
dollars the second couple is leading
with $150 now you selected the animal
kingdom and remember the more the
question is white the harder it is now
what do you want to start with ten fifty
sixty all the way up to 180 eighty
dollars what do you call a young or
nestling pigeon pea Said's on toast one
time I hope they agreed with you wobb
wobb is right yet we have $180 how are
you going to go for ninety ninety what
are you what kind of an animal is a
Flemish Giant boomers junk ah that's the
foul for nothing stinking
[Music]
guess oh you don't know well I'm sorry
it's a rabbit
oh no that's shame you lost half your
hundred eighty you have $90 all right
now what are you gonna go for seventy
seventy what do you call the rodents
that live in colonies on our American
Plains they have a bark resembling that
of a dog well that is you're a prairie
dog that's right a prairie dog is right
now have $160 it is your last chance to
be the other couples what're you gonna
go for 60 who's xhd what our Till's
golden eyes and canvasbacks deals rules
on each other's ducks
that's right doctors right and you wind
up with $220 thank you good luck in the
DeSoto Plymouth dealer
that means that mr. Sarles mr. Humiston
with $220 in just one minute get the
chance of the desoto plymouth one
thousand dollar question mr. Sarles and
mr. Huddleston all set for the desoto
plymouth thousand dollar question all
right here we go for $1,000 I'll give
you 15 seconds to decide on a single
answer which when you think Kathleen
please no help in the audience one of
the most famous cartoon characters that
the last 40 years as the timid soul
created by HT Webster for $1000 what is
this painfully timid character's name
[Music]
I
[Music]
all right why does the answer you two
have decided upon to go long yes it
wouldn't be sad ii know it's cash by
milquetoast hmm so that means the big
question next week will be worth $1,500
well they lost the big money but how
much they win the quiz George $220 well
thanks and congratulations to both of
you and to all of our contestants on the
show tonight